alors quand vous êtes un fou des mots on
va vous faire une interview par les
djeunes alors on va voir peut-être ça
sert votre prochain dictionnaire est ce
que vous savez ce que veut dire qui fait
sa race aux cetc l'équivalent de sam bot
non ouais voilà no soucy mais ça veut
dire no soucy bon no soucy fait lie la
live c'est du style
oui d'accord c'est un peu dégueulasse
d'autres trucs à meerab ccrp rap quand
on dit d'un truc que ses paires av
bah c'est un peu périmées qua non pour
yves ouais si jeudi pierre perret je
suis grave
vénère ça veut dire quoi très énervé
très bien
1 ce gag c'est quoi ce game alors là je
suis elle c'est dans mon dictionnaire
alors le tchi oui c'est ce que celle çi
le bail
j'y touche pas alors au chum est pas là
mais quand vous trouvez toutes vos idées
alors s et de l'ère bush y avait une
tasse pc quoi une tasse p ben c'est tout
sauf ma femme d'à coeur en tête c'est ce
que c'est un des prix mais bon c'est pas
mon truc c'est de la base c'est ce que
ça veut dire quand on dit c'est de la
balle c'est de la daube non non alors
c'est de la balle c'est super ça veut
dire aller alors c'est de la balle que
l'extra balle même pierre hanot entre
avec eux tu chies facile
alors ça c'est même pas du john essaie
de largo est assez vieux et ça fait
partie
ça fait partie du javanais matinée de
verlan peut se faire pépon veut mais
c'est péché moitié du matériau suivront
encore
et si je vous dis caire tu déchire à ça
me fait vachement plaidé m